Hello Arnold, my name is Joe Weider, how would you like to be the face of bodybuilding
I am training you to be the best in the world. Are your nuts. Are you?
What you do not realize is
All these men want is to compete against the very best 3..2..1
Copycats from Canada, huh?
Maybe he should be taken seriously
You do create strong competitors. Mr. Hauk, but to create an impeccable man
It takes dignity and grace qualities, you know, nothing about good luck. This is just the beginning
We will show him just how well our methods work you relentless Joe...oh my
You know what your problem is you have to man it up intensify
Let's do this
Deciding right
Kid welcome to the big time. We're the biggest and the best Joe
You win